hi i'm seth macfarlane and this is the
wired auto complete interview
i'm from new england we only respond to
negative criticism if you want to shut
on me i'm your i'm here
did seth macfarlane work on johnny bravo
i did work on johnny bravo that was
actually where i got my start at
hanna-barbera cartoon network i was a
writer and part-time storyboard artist
for johnny bravo for
season one and then
they fired us all and got some new guys
and you know
that's that's when the show went south
did seth macfarlane draw family guy i
did way back when my major was animation
in school so i designed the characters i
think it's safe to say they were they
were improved by other more talented
artists but the initial designs were
mine
did seth macfarlane leave family guy
stepped away around 2000
11 or so when when i started doing ted
and that was when i kind of handed it
off to the the show runners who are
who've been running it ever since yeah
these days i'm i'm i do voiceover on
family guy but that's really about it
did seth mcfarlane sing in sing same
word both a verb and a noun actually
yeah i did i sang uh i sang my way and a
couple of other uh sinatra tunes for for
the fabulous motion picture sing did
seth macfarlane make the simpsons hi i
[ __ ] wish no i did not make the
simpsons um i have a lot of very good
friends at the simpsons matt greening as
a friend and al gene and mike reese and
mike scully and those guys
that was that was actually legitimate
throw clear i wasn't trying to undercut
what i just said the simpsons definitely
had an influence on my work and i think
on the work of
every animated show that came afterwards
they rewrote the rule book so uh no i
did not but hopefully uh hopefully you
still like me
what does seth macfarlane look like
what are you a [ __ ] idiot
[Laughter]
uh what blank seth macfarlane blank this
is like i'm on the match game here know
what that is kids know what the match
game is gene rayburn nothing what voices
does seth mcfarlane do i know what
you're asking and i'll bark lick a seal
for you i i do peter i do stewie i do
brian and i do quagmire so those are the
those are the voices that i do for for
and and and stan and roger what is seth
macfarlane working on now i am working
on the orville which premieres june 2nd
and i'm also working on ted which is a
television series for peacock based on
the films the movie tarot if ted is a
film it's a movie what awards has seth
macfarlane won softball questions yeah
some a handful of emmys like the man
show awards right now the spike tv
awards one of those dude channels that
used to be around i got something from
them that had antlers on it
that's still in my house
what movies did seth macfarlane direct
directed three movies ted ted two and a
million ways to die in the west which is
a very concise title that if i had to do
over again i would listen to the
executives and come up with something
shorter yeah that's that's those
questions
who was seth macfarlane on gilmore girls
i think i was a graduating college
student
i was literally just taking taking shots
at lorelei gilmore and then i think my
sister and i sang a rendition of michael
rowe the bow to shore i think that was
my that was the extent of my gilmore
girl's tenure was friends with amy
palladino and and dan palladino so it
was it was a little bit of nepotism dan
palladino used to run family guy with me
and so when he left to go do gilmore
girls he took me with him i guess what
college
did seth macfarlane go to attend you
also could have said um i went to the
rhode island school of design superb
school they trained me to um to to make
family guy which i'm i'm sure
you know they regret at this stage but
uh yeah love risd loved my experience
great place highly recommended why does
seth macfarlane hate tucson it's not
tucson that i hate it's it's all of
arizona
does seth macfarlane own hulu
i do not own hulu i i have a
subscription to hulu if things keep
going better i'm going to get the one
without the commercials has seth
macfarlane been on broadway i have not
been on broadway no i i remember years
ago getting offered to come to use
spamalot
uh but i i was too busy making family
guy and i and as attractive as as that
offer was the timing didn't work out but
it's it's not out of the realm of
possibility i'm certainly open to it uh
why did seth macfarlane make american
dad because family guy got cancelled in
2002 or thereabouts created american dad
and then of course family guy came back
it was never my intention to have two
animated shows on the air at the same
time and i figured well it's all right
one of them will one of them will die
eventually and here we are years later
they're both still kicking
is seth macfarlane nice i guess it
depends on the hour of the day it's very
early right now but generally i try to
be i try to be kind is seth macfarlane
vegan i'm trying to phase out of meat
there's a taco bell late night now and
then that kind of disrupts things but in
general i'd say that's probably where
i'm where i'm headed is seth
macfarlane's friends with mila kunis we
better be because she she works for me
so
this this would this would not be good
but yeah no she's a good egg we're close
is seth macfarlane friends with ryan
reynolds uh yeah i'm also friends with
ryan reynolds yeah these are these are
very these are like really you guys you
guys be digging a lot deeper this is the
next one
when did seth macfarlane host snl i
think it was what
does that sound about right 2013 it was
before ted no it was after ted yeah
after ted so 2013. i think the musical
guest was frank ocean
that night when did seth macfarlane
become famous right now
like right here now because of this
wired
auto
complete interview i'm now officially
famous when did seth macfarlane start
singing i've been singing since i was a
little kid i was in a church choir if
you can believe that i think probably
from the age of age of five years old i
was i was singing when does south we're
into the present tense now when does the
orville take place the orville takes
place in the 25th century i think our
pilot uh was 24 17 was the date so yeah
there you go
how is
how how is seth macfarlane oh you're
asking how i am
i'm all right how did seth macfarlane
get his start i got my start at
hanna-barbera which was uh the very
famous cartoon studio that did
scooby-doo the flintstones the jetsons
did a little bit of work on the show
called dexter's lab before i got my my
real break running ace ventura the
animated series
how did seth mcfarlane get charlize
theron too let's just leave this one
let's i don't know what's under there uh
oh to be on the orville oh well that's
that puts a different paint job on this
charlize and i are very close we're very
very good friends and uh it just
i rolled the dice that maybe she was
just as cool as i thought she was and
turned out she was
how does seth macfarlane know patrick
stewart i was a fan of patrick stewart
for many years but i don't remember
exactly how i met him i had a couple of
friends
who wrote for star trek i think i may
have met him
that way i don't remember
how it came about i guess i guess we um
i don't know we have the same accountant
or something i don't i it doesn't it's
gone it's gone alrighty seth mcfarlane
full name
seth woodbury mcfarland seth macfarlane
william shatner impressions seth
macfarlane william shatner impression
seth macfarlane
favorite movie the sound of music can
you believe that who would have thought
the sound of [ __ ] music seth
macfarlane shoe size 11 and a half is
probably where it averages out you know
there's a couple of brands where it's
been like a 12. seth macfarlane is a
genius no no no no no no hardly i'm from
new england we only respond to negative
criticism so this is positive so i it
does nothing for me if you want to [ __ ]
on me i'm i'm you're i'm here that's it
okay what do i think about these
searches i think they're i think they're
hugely imaginative
i do wish i owned hulu yeah i do wish i
owned hulu
[Music]